our smart spatulas are designed for  spooning scooping scraping and stirring  a variety of samples or chemicals to  help remove the risk of  cross-contamination in other words a  fancy Slurpee straw certified for  laboratory use our smart spatulas are  manufactured from a high quality  polypropylene and can fit into a 0.2  milliliter centrifuge tube for small  sample transfer or mixing they are  resistant to diluted acids alcohol bases  and aqueous Solutions and can withstand  temperatures as low as liquid nitrogen  they also meet FDA standards for any  food and beverage applications both  sides can be used the spoon side is for  large Scoops and the back side is for  smaller scoops of sample